today welcome back to the rstudio
Enterprise Community Meetup
I think it was a little delayed there
for a few seconds so welcome back to the
rstudio Enterprise Community Meetup hope
everyone's having a great start to the
week very excited for our first steps in
learning the use of git and GitHub
Meetup today
if you've just joined now feel free to
say hi through the chat window maybe
where you're calling in from it's always
fun to see people calling in from all
over the world or listening in from all
over the world
a special welcome to you if this is your
first time joining us today this is a
friendly and open Meetup environment for
teams and people from the community to
share use cases teach lessons learned
just meet each other and and ask
questions in the chat as well and these
meetups happen every Tuesday or most
Tuesdays at 12 Eastern Time
I'll share a link in the chat where you
can find
other upcoming events too but together
we're all dedicated to making this space
inclusive and an open environment for
everybody no matter your experience or
industry or background
so during the event you can ask
questions wherever you are so if you're
watching on LinkedIn you can ask there
if you're on YouTube ask there as well
as anonymous questions uh through slido
and I'll show this on the screen here
just so you know where to find it but
you can ask anonymous questions there
I've also been experimenting with a few
polls and would love to hear your
thoughts over there too if we ask
questions
um so one thing that I'll ask everybody
now is
if you're joining us today do you use
Version Control for example get at work
today and I'll try launching the poll to
see if people want to answer over there
but thank you again so much for joining
us I would love to introduce today's
speaker Muna bellaid and Muna is
currently a business intelligence
consultant at Prime analytics she is
active in various Tech communities where
she co-founded Pi ladies Tunis and Tunis
are user groups she is also a member of
our ladies Global Arab R committees and
lead of Our Ladies Paris community so
with all that you may have seen a lot of
awesome events with Muna before on
LinkedIn too
I'll pull you over on stage here with me
thank you
thank you so much thank you all for
joining us yeah it's my pleasure thank
you for the nice introduction
so Muna I will head backstage and give
you the stage if you want to start
sharing your screen too thank you so
much yeah sure
so is it okay you are able to see my
screen
okay let me start so
um thank you all again for joining uh me
today and joining us so today
to people who use of a git and GitHub in
our studio so uh as introduced me just
briefly so I'm a business integers
consultant at Prime analytics and I'm
also the community organizer at eyelid
dispars this is where you can find me
like on Twitter or on LinkedIn
what about
um decision outline uh so I'll start
like giving an overview of Version
Control what are the benefits of Version
Control
um also share with you some popular
Version Control Systems we will see
what's git what's GitHub and then you
will move to
some practical parts and this is where I
will get really familiar with the use of
git and GitHub so what about the
requirements of uh for today's session
you should like have an R Studio
installed and also you need to have a
GitHub account and like have it also
installed on your local machine
yeah first uh what's uh Version Control
um so uh Version Control also known as a
source control uh is uh the practice of
uh trailer three
uh changes to the code for project
application or even each like software
component is typically organized in a
folder structure so Version Control will
help you uh to track every individual
change we make on the on the available
files in the code so by each contributor
in your teams and this step will help
you to prevent concrete work from I
would say conflicting so you know as
development environments have
accelerated visual Control Systems
nowadays will help you and is helping I
know the softwares
teams to work faster and I would say
smarter so what are the benefits of
vision control
um yeah so uh it will help you like
streamline your work
um instead maybe of spending your time
and inspecting and like reading over
whether this version is like of an Excel
file for example is uh is this is this
the the final version or it could be any
other file uh so visual control will
will help you to uh to be confident
about your analysis about your work and
like you can move to the next step it
will enable you to make uh to make your
work more reproducible is if you are
like a research and in this contest uh
context sorry I I want to tell you about
um like an illustrated series uh that
has been recently created by Alison
Hurst and Julia Stuart loans so the
figure that you are looking at and which
I found so so insightful
um is one of the amazing illustrations
that tell a story a good story about why
GitHub is so powerful for supporting uh
reusing contributing and failing safely
so Richard will kindly share with you uh
in the chat in a bit uh the link of this
series so that you get to know more
about this uh amazing work there are
really other amazing illustrations so
don't hesitate to look at them what are
the popular version control systems that
you have today so it could be like you
have git for sure but also there are
many other choices so like hvs but here
we are going to focus on just one git
yeah what's good
um so this is an open source software so
um and is a distributed Version Control
like software uh what's its function it
will as I said so it will help you to
manage the evolution
um of a set of files that you have and
what you call a repository okay
being distributed means that every
developer working with a git reposo has
a copy of that entire repository I mean
every comment every Branch every file so
it it was initially development in 2005
um so by the Linus turvals and so he's
who's the one many of the Linux
operating system economic disaster
information
yeah then what
so uh GitHub is the collaboration
platform
and
um it's the most popular uh hosting
service for uh collaborating on code
using it so other of other hosting
Services
um include may include beat buckets and
gitlab okay
so uh come back to this series another
second illustration for the GitHub
illustration series that I have talked
about to you uh in a moment ago and
what's the definition of collaboration
so by Jenny Bryan so collaboration is
the most compelling reason to manage a
project with Git and GitHub so my
definition of collaboration includes
like Hands-On participation by multiple
people like in a team including gearbox
and future self and I really like this
definition
yeah
uh maybe before moving I'd like getting
started
um with like with it I can like have
some questions if there are any
questions in the chat I would be happy
to to answer
so I just checked over to slido and I
don't see any questions yeah okay I just
want to remind people that if you do
want to ask any questions you can ask
them either on LinkedIn if you're
watching there or on YouTube but you can
also use the slider link here on the
screen to ask anonymous questions too
um
and I was trying to do a live pull to
see and looks like we have 50 people so
of people so far who answered that use
Version Control uh 17 no and 33 learning
to to use it right now so feel free to
go answer the poll over there too but I
will uh I'll let you continue and we'll
hold questions till then
okay perfect
uh so
first of all you need to check that git
is installed okay to do so we'll use the
terminal of our studio
uh so from the terminal so our studio
like provides access to the to the Shell
from uh from its environment from our
studio so to do so I will move to Arrow
Studio okay and let's see uh what we get
by entering the flowing command which
git okay
so I hope that you are like you have my
screen where I show you
perfect so on my side I will just type
which git so I will check if I have git
installed so it's okay I know that I
have git installed so normally for me on
my side I should get this um this path
so this one should be the path of my git
uh executable on your side for people
maybe who didn't install uh yet
installed these you should maybe get an
error like a command not found uh it's
okay uh just to have you should install
it uh also maybe the terminal which
should be next to the console here tab
if this one is not visible what you can
do is like go to tools
Okay click once doesn't work it's okay
so normally you should go to tools then
uh you should see terminal at another
option after two
terminal sorry to to get it uh visible
okay
yeah what about uh the version that I
have uh the Git Version that I have
today on my local machine just to to
check this I will write it
Double Dash version so for each command
for each bit command it's okay that we
will have git at the start okay so on my
side I have this
Git Version on my Windows machine
okay
let me go back to the slide
yeah what about communicating
communicating with GitHub uh yeah so
when you want to when you want to
interact with a remote git server shuts
uh such as GitHub uh you need to
to include some credationals in our
request which proves that you are a
GitHub user that is allowed to do some
operations so uh so git can communicate
with GitHub based on two protocols uh is
HTTP TPS or SSH so and the two protocols
like use different predictions so for
our case we will use this one https and
to do so you need to um to create a
personal access token so in the past it
was possible to to use the the password
okay that is associated with your GitHub
account but nowadays it's like uh it's
no longer possible it could be possible
with other hosting services but for
GitHub you should generate this token
okay and to do so so you need to go to
this directory okay it will click call
so it's okay I have this page open
if you click what you should be redirect
redirected to the page so this is a
GitHub I will come back later in the
Practical
um parts to explain more about GitHub
but let's now focus on speech okay
so uh this is where we'll generate the
personal access token so whenever you
are like doing uh like you are doing a
bit uh you are executing a bit command
and you are asking to provide your token
you should do okay so these are for
example the token that I have generated
because each day you can have has an
expiration date it's okay you receive an
email Associated that is associated I
mean an email addresses Associated
account to generate a new one so for
example for me if you uh if I want to
generate a new token I'll click on this
button okay
so we'll click on this one the classic
oh I should configure this on my mobile
it's okay
so oh
I think I will do this it's here fine
I can confirm my access so you can you
should give um give a name to your new
personal access token uh on my side I'll
just do uh
I'll just give it a name as Pat personal
access token
um also you should you should Define the
Scopes what does it mean that means the
the rights that you want to give to this
token so generally what is and what is
recommended to select is this one the
repo then
um how to create this and the workflow
so I will not I won't click on this
button generator you can because already
I have one but
on your side you can click on generator
token this button and you should get the
token that should not be visible to
anyone and you should
um you should save it save it maybe in
the file secure file but what is also uh
provided by other studio is like you can
use uh the the library use this in other
studio so let me come back to my slides
and you can do the following in our
studio by typing these two commands
using the use this Library so these two
commands will help you to store your Pat
so whenever you are asking ask it to
provide it it's possible to provide it
okay
so I will just make a copy of this code
and come back to my
window where I have R Studio ad always
in the terminal maybe I will have
okay I will paste it here
so what about the First Command create
GitHub I will just run Ctrl enter yeah
this is what I get so to okay it will
so you can also create a new token using
this command but let's say that it's
okay I have my token but I want to
um to be able to get access to it so I
will come back to our studio and using
the the second command Ctrl enter yeah
so this is what I get as option
so one two three so uh let me see yeah
so it it will ask you if you want to
keep this graduation yes I want to keep
my my token I want to I won't change it
if you want to replace uh them or if you
want to see the password or toy pen so
if I will click we'll see it will it's
okay I will the token will be visible to
me so um this time I'm not I'm not like
uh obliged to uh to save it in a secure
file so I will have the token here
so after
get after setting up the communication
between delete and GitHub
you need to introduce ourselves to to be
so who are you as user let's go to the
next step yeah so in the other studio uh
you need to type each
um each line like each command line
separately so you need to Define uh your
user mail and this one must be the same
also associated with your GitHub account
um
the second and for the username it's
okay it has not been to be the your um
your username on GitHub you can like
choose anyone else so for me I will make
I've just made a copy so it's okay on my
side I know that I have everything set
up but if you want to check that um so
that it's okay git knows you you come
back to our come back to our studio and
in the terminal let me go back to the
terminal
I'll just write git
config
then Double Dash list
okay I'm not able to see very I think I
get a yeah
ah I forget something sorry setting it
up get
yeah so normally your username and your
your image should be displayed okay I
have a problem with my screen
and this is how you define like we
introduce ourselves to it
so I think you have some questions in
the chat if you can like have some
questions it's fine for me Russia
yeah so I think one of the questions was
um someone was asking if we could put
our commands in the chat and so I just
shared the slides in both the YouTube
and Linkedin I'm perfect
take them from there too
yeah let's see another question was
um I think so Mark asked and I think
this might be specific to like
the GitHub account if I'm a consultant
or switch between teams does a singular
account make sense
that you want to use a single GitHub
account right
feel free to comment or or add any other
contacts in the chat too
yeah sure so what I would recommend is
like because it's possible to uh as a
team it's possible to work on the same
GitHub repository from different
accounts like each one in the team has
its own GitHub account and like you are
collaborating in the same account so
it's okay each one should have its
GitHub account it's like safer yeah I
would say
um and then I think another question was
earlier can we push our work from
our Cloud to GitHub
yeah this is this is new in our studio
so I didn't try it but I I have seen the
the get pain in our studio Cloud so it
should do it should work
yes awesome thank you I don't see any
other questions in the chat yet let me
just go jump over to
slido again and I'll just
put this up on the screen too just so
you know if you want to ask questions
anonymously too you can use this link
here r s t d dot IO Meetup Dash
questions
cool thank you perfect yeah thank you
um so now uh let's now go to the next
part getting the most out of GitHub edit
so we learned to do two things
first of all how to create a new R study
project okay and push it to GitHub so
during this part we will learn how to
create a GitHub repo and how to link it
to your project on your own machine the
second part
so is about cloning an existing GitHub
repository to understood your project
and during this part we will learn about
how to connect a new R Studio project
started from scratch to a GitHub
so so you need to understand the process
the terminology okay let's say you want
to contribute to a repository of an open
source project on GitHub okay so here
you are able to see the remote
repository on remote repository on
GitHub then you will use git clone to uh
first you will Fork it sorry it's that
means that you will make a copy of this
repo so that
um you make changes to a project without
affecting the original one the original
repository so it's okay you have the
copy then you will use git clone okay
the command to make a copy that means
that you you are making a good copy of
this repository on your local machine
then like you can work uh locally on
this project by making changes on the
available files
then you need to uh to add the updated
files on which you made a chance to what
you call the stitching area and this is
by using git add
however git doesn't really affect the
repository like in any significant way
why because changes are not actually
recorded until you run git commit
and let's step you need to push these
changes to the remote remote GitHub repo
so to make your updated files like
available to your collaborates okay to
people who are working with you in the
same team
um last thing also if other people are
like working on the same project uh on
the same repository I mean or maybe also
you are working on a different computer
you can pull uh you should like pull
back pull any changes back first to your
local repository so like everything is
synchronized okay you see the point
yeah so
um this is an overview of the git
commands along so with their
explanations explanation sorry
um that you should know as a beginner so
I have already covered a part of them uh
that should be but that should be also
helpful for people who will have a look
um at the slides later
yeah I was just gonna ask well you had
that uh
um a few people were asking about some
of the commands that you covered earlier
um so that they could use them and
mention that some of them were in the
linked slides would you be able to just
cover some of the commands that you you
used initially
this comments
um yes just for like just a refresher
for people who are following a lot and
setting it up too yeah
yeah sure so let's say that you have a
directory on our studio if you would
like to create an empty git repository
to to have this uh this new directory
like under under Version Control we will
for example we will execute like git in
it and you will put the link of this
directory so this directory uh will be
like Android version control so if it
changes on the file that we have in this
directory uh will be track it will be
like you can accommit them and you can
work after this you can work with the
kit commands git clone that means that
you will
um make a copy of this repository and
this repository which is normally on
GitHub should be like on your local
machine okay and git config this is how
you introduce ourselves to git because
uh like when if you get want you want to
if you want it wants to communicate with
a remote server shuts is such as GitHub
you need to introduce ourselves that
means that you need to to and results
about by username and also uh you need
you have another comment about git
config user email you should put the
email associated with our GitHub account
okay I think I I just clarified the
question in the chat there's actually
the ones that you used previously in our
studio so where you started with use
this
just a refresher for people following
along yeah okay awesome thank you yeah
you are welcome so first of all you need
to as a first user as a new user you
need to generate a token so this token
should be generated from GitHub so from
GitHub you have a page settings and you
should generate this one because
sometimes when you are working with it
it could be that it will ask you about
your about yourself who are you so you
should be allowed to do some operations
between git and GitHub so when he git
will ask you about this you should
provide these personal access token so
either we'll do we'll go over these
steps manually like here okay and you
will click or generate token but also as
our studio here is like wonderful and it
provides uh us like with the basic
edited client through the git pane that
you have here on the right side also you
have these these use this Library which
normally should is useful for automating
some repetitive tasks and also is useful
for here to generate this token so using
this command if I click once I will be
redirected to GitHub and like generate a
new token and this command will allow
you to save this token so whenever you
need this token you don't have to like
to save it in Secure file on your
computer maybe if you show if you run
this command once you will get the will
get access to this um to this to this
type in here okay and then you should
provide this to git when it asks it asks
you about it yeah then I was like just
um going through this
table
thank you yeah so yeah and just so
everybody knows too that those
um those commands are in the the slides
it's just one of the slides is
interactive so you can click on like
yeah sure there's options yeah you need
to make a copy yeah
yeah and if you want to communicate with
GitHub just you have the steps here you
can follow
but you can reach out to me later either
we'll go through these steps or also
from our studio just you need to make a
copy of these two commands Okay thank
you so much this is an important uh yes
I will come then you need to take it who
you are like you define your username
and your email and then just uh so you
didn't get you didn't you didn't go
through these steps okay from this part
I'm just explaining I was just
explaining the terminal about like using
deal and GitHub and now uh I will like
go through this first
um first practical type it's about
um we learn about about how to create
another Studio project and like to push
it together okay that means that you
learn how to set up this a local
repository like you will create a new
art studio project now and then I will
link it to a remote repository okay
we'll go through this together
so you I have steps here but also I
would like to go this like in live now
okay so let me go to our studio and um
create a new R study project
so I will go here
so to create a new R Studio project
we'll click on this button to create a
project
are you sure you want yes
yeah you should get this
um this window so you just click on new
directory
then we click on your project as you
want to create new one then you should
give a name to the directory so let me
first maybe
um change the uh the directory so I will
browse to my files and I'll choose this
one
I will give it a name
like repo one because we have later
another repository about two so this is
a local repository this is a local
directory make sure to keep this one
selected okay because as you want to
create a git repository remember later
when I told you about the use of the
command git in it it's like you are
creating a directory under Version
Control so here are Studio you don't
need to write this command you just need
to keep this one selected it's like it
in it if you want to write it in the
terminal okay you see the terminology so
just you create open new session okay
algorithm create project
so I'm generating a new one so what's
the what's the the objects of this part
it's like let's say you you started a
project okay and then you want to
collaborate
um on this project with other team
members so to do so we think about the
the so it's it's useful to use git and
GitHub so that's why you will um you
will have also a copy of this repository
like on uh on on GitHub okay so later I
will create a repository on GitHub and
live and like connect the local
repository to the remote repository so
everything every child that you make on
the local repository like you can push
it and also you can pull back the
changes that maybe wouldn't be made by
your team members from GitHub to your
local Repository
uh so what you have here just you have
two files that should be listed here uh
on the bottom right here and also if you
would have a look at the git
at the git pane you should see these two
files
so to
um before moving to our to GitHub and
creating
um the uh the repository you should
um
you should have these files under
Version Control what does this mean you
should this file should be tracked later
so first of all instead of using the
command lightline git add here from this
um from this git pane from us our studio
you just need to tick the boxes that you
have under the stage color like this the
first one should be selected also
because I clicked right
once again
you should not take so much time okay I
don't know but it's fine
so you are like adding adding these two
files uh to what you call a sieging area
go ahead yeah after doing so you need to
click on Commit that means you need to
save this operation to save these files
okay
so we click on Commit you should get
another window this is the review
challenge window
so it appears on the screen right
you should get this window the review
changed
normally you should get all the because
for now like this is a directory like
started from scratch we don't really
have any changes to to be triggered okay
but normally you should see like the
changes here and like in um with an
output like for for changes we've been
read and for for and for uh for things
that you kept should be in green and
like and this is what you should get
okay then you need to um to leave a
comment messages so what what why this
is useful because for someone else this
commit messages should be later
displayed on the GitHub and the
repository that is connected to this
local repository so someone else when
when we see this file with this comments
messages he will end he will be able to
understand why what's the objectives of
these comment steps okay so what is
recommended is like you use um a verb
then you describe like you start your
um your comment message with the verb so
for example let's say uh
great
new directory new
after doing so you need to save you need
to click on the comment button like this
so you have the information
uh there are things so don't focus on
all the information but the main things
is that you are saving the two files
okay then you need to close this window
and also close this one and what you can
see in this git pane that everything is
um is strict like this proves that
because the two files disappeared and
which proves that this is a successful
comment okay now I will move to our 2
GitHub sorry and I will create a new
repository so what does it mean to
create so first this is let's go to the
home page here to create a new
repository you should have the green
button here to start a new one
you click on this one once
yeah so you should provide some Mission
so for example for me because
um I'm managing some organization on
GitHub so I should select my name so my
profile who's the one who will create
this repository it's not like none of my
the organizations that I manage so I
will choose this one on your side if you
don't have any organization should be
this your name should be automatically
displayed
you should provide a repository name so
this is an important information that a
repositories uh should be like at its
displayed short and you should not have
um white spaces in the names okay either
you use underscores or just don't leave
any spaces between
um your name the name that you will give
to a new repository on GitHub
so
according to our practical part the
repository name here should be the same
one as the same one as our directory in
our studio so on our side the name is
Ripple one so this one should be the
same so what you are trying to do here
is that you are trying to to have these
um this Earth to You directory and
reversial control okay
let me go back to uh and I'll just type
rip one
also you can put a description but it's
okay I will move to the next part
um because this just tests a repository
for test you can choose if you want to
have his repository public or private
also
um it's important also to choose your
license if you want to uh to share uh
your work it's important to do so but
for now I I will move and I will click
on this button okay create Repository
so what you should get here
on this quick setup page
you should get many codes
um so useful for various uh situations
on our side what you want to do is that
you want to push an existing repository
from the command line that means you
will use this you need just to to make a
copy of these command lines
if I want to maybe let's break down
these command line so what does it mean
that means so for every git command it's
okay we'll have git at the beginning
then a remote ad this is
um this is how you want to configure
another repository that should contain
the same
um the same content the same information
the same files that you have on our
local machine on our like record
directory okay so that's why we will
remove origin
this is the unique name that you will um
so instead of using each time this the
following address web address we will
use this nickname origin to refer to
this
um web address okay I will make a copy
of this code
I will go back to our studio and
to the terminal where I can execute
the git command
yeah click ones right
sorry it's okay
yeah so let me make
full I will make a copy of this
ah because it should be yeah it should
not be Ctrl V for Windows machine it
should be shift
uh insert to make a copy to make a paste
operation yeah this is the first command
then I will make a copy for the first
the second one
so should be
um shift plus insert to paste enter
and then using this command git push
Dash origin means so instead of using
this long web address you will use a
origin here that means every change
later that you will be making on our
our studio directory if you push it it's
possible to push these exchanges to this
uh to make it available to make it
available to your uh to the color birds
that you have on your team maybe you are
working the same project
I hope that I'm clear enough author was
not easy at least to ask your question
in the chat okay I'll make a copy for
the last one yeah
so now
yeah fine
if I go back like
refresh my page and let's have a look
now at this 3.1 Repository
yeah as you can see now this repository
is not empty because I have two files
here that I have on this um on this our
studio directory what is also
recommended when you work with
repository in GitHub is like you have a
redmi file okay so we will have this
file like you will have um a description
of your of your repositories or someone
else when you look uh at your repository
he knows like about the project the
process maybe you want to include some
some code in this readme file so let us
have a redmi file here so we'll click on
this button
and then
so for information this redmi file is
and marked the format so this one MD is
short for
markdown format
so I'll just write here this is
or a test repository or just make it
simple welcome
to the session
you need then to save
you can also add another like an
optional description if you want but you
can like say by clicking on comment new
file
okay
so the file now is
is available on GitHub but what about
the git uh sorry what about our studio
did you have the file here no for sure
why because you need to pull the changes
back to our local machine to our local
directory and how we will do this we
need to click on this button about pool
we'll pull these changes back okay
just equals
and because you have this information
one file and if you will have a look
here that you have the readme file here
and for sure if you want to add like a
new script sorry here you need to push
this centers to the to get her okay I
hope that it was clear for you otherwise
like you have everything normally should
be here on this part
steps
before you like
yeah I was thinking one question over
from slido that might be uh useful to
cover right now if somebody asked when
making a copy with a fork and then
working on the files and pushing the
changes does the original project
um is the original project affected by
that
um
yeah so so the question is when you Fork
a copy of GitHub uh does that then make
any changes to the original project
ah no no when you make when you make it
you take a copy from the project no so
because because later when you will put
you pull your sentence back to this
repository it will be uh throw a pull
request so someone who the the one who
is managing the repository on GitHub has
a choice to approve your charges or not
so now when you make a copy it's okay
you will not it's it's like it's not
your original your original the original
repository but it's like your own
original repository like you can do what
you want but the other person either
will approve your your chances or not I
hope that was clear
thank you yeah that's something that was
always confusing to me and and just like
I I'm just getting started as well but
knowing the difference between like uh
cloning a repository or forking
repository and like if it notifies
people as well like if you're just
trying to learn from someone's example
yeah it's okay like if you have a
repository and you um you Fork it
that means that will be available to you
on your GitHub account
um if you if then you will clone it that
means that you will have this repository
on your local machine from your GitHub
account to your local machine after this
if you want to make some changes they
will put we'll put these changes uh we
will pull solid distance back to your um
GitHub repository and being on your
GitHub repository this time will like
create a pull request and
um like uh request if you if you if if
the the one who is managing the
repository wants to accept them or not
the chance that you you made
so to just double check so it if for
anybody who's just getting started if
you aren't trying to make a pull request
but you just want to use somebody's
example and adapt it would you then just
clone
yeah you can do it you can because you
you have access also to what you call
branches so like you have the main
branches Branch then you have other
branches that could be like created by
other people other contributors and you
can have access to them
great thank you
yeah so let me go
um thank you all for your attention let
me move to the second part and generally
this is the approach that is
um that is like followed okay
um
yeah I will go back here
so um the second approach
um that you might follow is that
um when you you use if that you set up a
remote GitHub repository first okay and
then you try to connect
um another studio uh to these
um GitHub repository so you have some
steps here uh but what I will do so I
will go first to
uh so for me I don't have any uh
so normally it should yeah so let's say
you have a repository on GitHub okay
already you have this one on GitHub you
should uh this time this is what you
call Will clone this repository so to do
so to clone this repository we will go
to uh normally you should have this one
this green button code and you clone it
so either we'll make a copy of this uh
of this code so already you have this
button here
thank you
and then you come back to our studio I
will make sure to close this
uh
I'm not see I'm not saying close project
fine so let me have a new R Studio
project you click on this button again
but this time will not click on new
directory because already you are citing
a project from like a Version Control
like repository okay from GitHub so
click on this one and this time so it
will work with Git or subversion so
we'll clone a project from this git
repository that you have online
and then you provide this link okay
and don't try to change
um to change the name okay because this
one should be the same the name of the
repository on your organization should
be the same online
and then open your session or it's okay
I can have the other one ah because yeah
it's okay it's good that you get this
error
this way you can learn something new
yeah destination path already uh because
already this directory is under Version
Control so it's not possible so what I
will do is that I will I will very
quickly create a new Repository
so when you get this error that means
that already you try to connect a local
repository to a GitHub repository
and this one is already under visual
control so I will try to create a new
one
repo
they select this one and this time I can
start like having readme file at the
beginning
and I don't need
uh I don't need the license I'm not
working on a project important
so for depository I have only redmi file
I will make a copy I that means I will
clone this repository this is the right
word come back to so I need to close
this one already exists yeah
I will create a new
project on our studio
then git then
you put this name and don't send this
one yeah should be in the same folder
then create
project
as you can see cloning into this
Repository
and if I want to
let's create a new R script okay
this time I want to like to practice the
operation so I will have new R script
here
foreign
and I will just write I don't know print
so this time I will try welcome to this
session I'll try to put this changes to
GitHub okay
Ctrl R it's okay I will save this file
welcome
oh my God it's okay
fine
so if you get our repository you don't
have this R script
that's why you need first to add this
file to the staging area
I will get back to my git pane here
thank you
yeah and then you need to click once on
each box under the stagered column
otherwise you can use the terminal
and write git add white space points and
all these files should be
um
should be like a staged
why it gets sometimes it's fine
thank you
so what I would like to do is like it
add
s and then
this one should work so you need to
commit
you should get the review changes window
where you will put
[Music]
um
a comment description
you should get this window again
yeah it's okay everything is
as I told you you should get every
chance like in the um the green color
okay uh update
available
and then you click on this button
comment
you can close
now if I get back I won't see my file
okay even I refresh because I need to
push this this file okay
okay now if I come back
I believe I will see my script
yeah I can see my welcome R5 here
uh
so here maybe it's time to um to tell
you about the Gigi type cheat that I
have created
um I will tell you about like quickly
about the process that I have worked
through to um to submit this and utility
to the um cheat sheets guitar repository
with like Google requests so
this is
um this is a little repository that uh
that contains the source of files of the
current archived and every like
translated version of the
um Chichi so
um Russia will kindly share with you the
link in a bit
um so uh you have like some folders
um the png's format of these uh of these
teachings the Keynotes and power bronze
folders so for example
um as I told you the png's folder will
contain the image format so first I I
forked the repository okay as I told you
in a moment ago then I cloned the
um cheat sheets GitHub repository
then uh as as I showed you I will click
on the I clicked on the green
um green so the the button clone or
download button and like I made a copy
of the
um I made a copy of the link
after this after like creating uh the
cheat sheets and like converting it to a
PDF uh format and to PowerPoint format I
put the pdf version of this uh cheat
sheet in the PDF and I also did the same
for the PowerPoint version and I
included the the image of the first page
um yeah I will commit uh comments or and
then I created a pull request okay these
are the steps that I were talking about
and a moment ago and and then here I
like provide some information about this
one in like you should have this section
below so I highly encourage you to to to
go through these initiatives like maybe
you you have like some interesting topic
you you feel like worship is missing uh
so don't hesitate to uh to go over this
uh maybe I can show you should be this
one okay
uh yeah if you want to keep uh learning
so I I will highly recommend uh a book
which was written by uh Jenny Bryan so
this one happy kid and guitar for the
use are this is so useful also there is
very useful
um full like opposite documentation
provided by GitHub and there is also an
interesting free course provided by
GitHub introduction to GitHub
thank you all your attention I would be
happy to answer any other questions and
this is where you can find me thank you
awesome thank you so much Muna I am I
just shared some of those links into the
chat there and your cheat sheet as well
it's really helpful to see an example of
how you use this in practice with
contributing to the r Studio cheat sheet
so thank you so much for doing that it's
incredibly helpful thank you for having
me it's my pleasure
I see that there are a few other
questions I think from the chat and in
slido but I just wanted to remind people
that
um you can ask questions where you are
on YouTube or LinkedIn but you can also
ask questions anonymously on slido
and one of those questions was
how do we ignore the dot r
uh project and get ignore an initial
push to GitHub if you only want the code
files in GitHub
um so you if I show you the git ignore
you should like just
if I'm wrong okay I let me go to
so because normally
bring
invicted file
if you try to open it
you should get the extensions of the
file that you want like git to ignore so
as I know
you should have the list of the
extensions of the file that you want
that git
um ignore okay
I don't know yeah
but thank you
yeah I see
um
there is another question that actually
was over on the Meetup discussion which
I usually don't see the questions there
too so great great to see that there as
well but Mike asks what are effective
project management structures with
GitHub keeping just the code it makes
sense I have used data code and com as
folders under the respective project
parent but this can lead to a myriad
repositories and folders and would like
to limit these
yeah I I will also uh recommend like
having a folder when data may be when
you should have your
um your data sets having the codes in
another folder and if you have some
slides some presentation some other
useful files I would say
awesome thank you
a lot of people
see a lot of people saying thank you in
the chat I just want to make sure I
haven't missed a specific questions
okay something I am curious about and
yeah we know how to ask this question
but when we're learning to use
get and GitHub and like something just
goes terribly wrong and it's just like
not working is there how do you like
restart or refresh
yeah sure so it's okay I will have a
look at the error at Google first of all
yeah specially stuck overflow but I
would really recommend uh the book of
Genie Bryan because there is an
interesting part about troubleshooting
uh very frequent errors that you may get
so this is like my my first move so I
moved to this book and then I will try
to search on also on the GitHub
documentation
um or just you can also reach out to me
if I can help it's okay
awesome thank you so much
um I want to also um oh wait someone
else just asked a question yeah
JD or apologies if I pronounce your name
wrong but you said thank you how often
do you recommend committing and pushing
should we push every commit
yeah
um good question I yeah because uh
because everything when you made a
commit like every change you made will
be
um will be saved and will be like
displayed for your collaborators so like
make a commit when you are really sure
that will be useful uh for tricking
later and don't like just made a commit
for maybe 10 examples like a commit who
is which is worth it so I don't really
recommend to make mini comments I don't
want to to make um to say number because
it depends if your project is like it's
complex is uh is composed of many many
steps during this project but I won't
recommend doing so many comments
thank you
um
so one other question is like if you're
just starting at using GitHub and you
want to use it for like your own private
project and you don't want everybody to
be able to see your code what do you
recommend
it's okay you can make uh your GitHub
repository private because I also did
this before making my uh my like my
files public
um it's okay to opt for a private
repository so GitHub allows you to do so
great I see one other question that just
came through on YouTube
uh is how do you manage a public repo
how do you get the community outside
your project to interact with your code
yeah you can you can uh go through this
through the issues so this is like a
thread like when you where you have some
discuss the discussions sorry and uh
like you get interactions on your maybe
some uh suggestions of improvements uh I
maybe I didn't cover the the issues but
I I would recommend like
um going through them issues having some
issues on the like an important
repository like for example the cheat
sheets repository I can see
um many many requests to have uh to
improve the the some requests to improve
the repositories the the sheets provide
today
great thank you so much I think that
we've gone through all the questions if
we missed anything I'll give people a
few more seconds to copy that back into
the chat here so I see it pop up
thank you so much Muna for for walking
us through this and giving us such a
great introduction I appreciate all the
the helpful resources you've shared as
well
um I did want to let people know if
you'd love to join a future event we'd
love to see you there
um so you can use this link here it's
actually a quarto doc where you can see
upcoming community events so we have
meetups like this on Tuesdays we also
have data science Hangouts on Thursdays
I would love to see you there Muna if
you have any upcoming events too with
some of the groups that you work with
feel free to to share those too
ah yeah thank you all for joining us
also you will be wisdom to join us at
early disperse Community uh I don't know
if I have a link okay maybe I can put it
in the chat right now too
yeah thank you
uh let's see I'll start I'll start with
the Our Ladies Paris Twitter because
that's what I found first but I think
the link to it is on there too
it's okay that would be wonderful thank
you all for joining us awesome thank you
so much have a great rest of the day
everybody thank you so much Muna thank
you goodbye